johanne cormier vice président principal
de la division poulet chez exceldor
bonsoir bonsu fillon le ministre boulet
vous propose l'arbitrage pour mettre fin
immédiatement aux conflits qu'est ce que
vous répondez à cette proposition
écoutez on accueille favorablement toute
mesure board arbitrage qui permet de
mettre en arrêt immédiat au gaspillage
alimentaire donc on a déjà donc vous
êtes d'accord avec l'arbitrage mais vous
devez faire une demande d'arbitrage en
accord avec le syndicat n'est ce pas
reparti pour encourager pas grâce à des
détails compresses et chaque partie doit
accepter la nomination de l'arbitré pour
nous faut des d'exceldor comme j'ai
mentionné c'est une option qui est
favorable comme tout autre mesure qui
permettrait l'arrêt du gaspillage est
l'enjeu principal c'est sur lequel on
trouve que c'est quelqu'un qui doit
avoir un arrêt immédiat
déjà qu est ce un million de loisirs de
cétacés est ce qu'à votre connaissance
le syndicat accepte l'arbitrage pour
répondre malheureusement ce fillion à
cette question là j'ai pas eu
l'information
je pense qu'ils ont été contactés nommé
jeu pot 2 par le ministre mais j'ai pour
les formations
etes-vous en contact avec le syndicat
escape quelques pourparlers que ce soit
avec la partie syndicale en ce moment
pour écouter c'est un peu aussi ce qui a
motivé la sortie aujourd'hui une
rencontre de la domination les actrices
en chef favorablement dernières semaines
et puis la prochaine et plus seulement
que patrick sanville on trouve que le
temps c'est dur il faut que faut qu'on
arrête ce gaspillage encore une fois
mais est ce que quand même les
négociations avançaient ce qui est des
pourparlers qui font en sorte qu on
avance pas à pas vers une entente
potentielle non comme on en est là
comment on en arrive là
il semble y avoir un écart abyssal entre
votre proposition est ce que demande le
syndicat dans un secteur tellement
important pour l'économie les abattoirs
et
considérant des emplois qui souvent se
font dans des conditions de travail
quand même difficile à écouter c'est
pour ce que lorsqu'on a déposé notre
finale
on a pris la décision du avec une offre
finale et globale qui permet à des
conditions parmi les plus avantageuses
en amérique du nord
pour ces travailleurs leur
reconnaissance de ce milieu de travail
là et on a même ouvert la porte à la
partie syndicale devassy des éléments de
temps voulu réaménagé dans cette
proposition n'ont découvert à tour et
aménagement d'intérieur cette
proposition alors mais en même temps
comprendre il suffit donc on doit garder
l'entreprise compétitive à long terme et
des contrats renouvelés donc faut rester
à l'intérieur du marché même si cette
proposition ne lui mettez la chef de
file on la connaît pas bien
l'industrie donc on vous dit que la
compétitivité ça veut dire quoi par
exemple combien gagnent les employés
chez vous les employés sont avaient dans
leur chalet on dit on a déposé une heure
de 22h51 pour pour la première ligne mon
200 quand il est où demande combien
va-t-il boyle et m6 avant au début elle
a tout fait important c'est de l'autre
côté c'est lui toni % d'augmentation la
première lan et 18 pour ça sur six ans
la demande est de 25 pour sa première
l'un des 40 % sur 3 1 peuvent comprendre
est que cette position ne nous met des
avantages notamment par rapport à la
compétition ou mais en 2009 d'avoir des
pertes épouvantable un million de
poulets et en asie
est-ce que par jari toujours mal à
comprendre mais pas un chemin à faire
entre le 22 dollars 50 et 2,25 dollars
ici on écoute et on a joué pour entrer
dans les détails de la négociation des
discussions qui ont eu lieu y des idées
raconte avec beaucoup de rencontres avec
avoir même avait dans les airs et sans
chercher un médiateur au dossier il ya
plusieurs rencontres quand je vous
inscrire ça fait cinq jours donc on
n'est pas loin
souvent on parle des conditions de
travail dans les abattoirs qui sont
difficiles je pense que la pandémie l'a
bien exposé compte tenu des 99 qui a eu
dans plusieurs abattoirs au québec est
ce qu'on n'a pas un devoir de votre côté
quand même d'ajuster la situation les
conditions de travail des employés
et c'est ce qu'on a tenu compte dans
notre offre finale qui permettait de
rencontre plusieurs éléments pour rendre
ces conditions le plus agréable au
niveau des usines je vous dirais
cependant
d'ailleurs on l'a démontré au cours des
pandémies le nez à nez beaucoup de
choses ont été mis en place
que fait en sorte que les impacts de la
maladie aux uv besson était quand même
moins que ce qu'on a pu observer dans
d'autres dans d'autres milieux
donc je vous dirais de ce côté là on est
quand même assez fiers chez le thunder
du travail on le fait avec nos employés
ça s'est fait à perdre en partenariat
avec eux pour assurer des conditions
saines de travail avec ses chambres et
dernier point vous avez pas un choix
d'euthanasier des bêtes qui ne sont pas
correctement a battu ses des pertes
c'est du gaspillage complète écoutez on
est tous deux compères question est
bonne
oui parce que m l'inde a rapporté que 7
950 mille oiseaux par semaine que l'usm
de cet ancien transforme
on a placé présentement depuis le début
du conflit on a placé une partie si ce
beau jour là du côté du nouveau
brunswick
on en a placé chez des compétiteurs ici
au québec on a déplacé les spots et de
l'ontario et même depuis le week-end
dernier on en place pour des américains
mais les capacités partout dans l'est du
canada sont limitées les abattoirs
compétition face à des manques de main
d'oeuvre du fait que le capacités sont
limitées
et là ça nous laisse de ma poche choix
effectivement une fois moins de fait
tout ce qu on a rempli toutes les
capacités partout ben alors faut
procéder à l'euthanasie
et vous savez pour excédent qui est une
coopérative comporte 400 membres
producteurs de poulets 100% de rumeurs
infondées production de poulets il y en
a deux cent soixante au quai d de ses
membres
c'est sûr que ça nous interpelle on peut
préparer ces cinq sensible à cet enjeu
la détruit des oiseaux qui emmène le
gaspillage épouvantable voilà c'est je
n'ai eu jamais vu merci monsieur cormier
d'avoir été avec nous merci ce film pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh